What do you think of when you think of Pirates?
Do you conjure up images of fearless sea dwellers,
cruising the high seas?
Perhaps you think of the more violent realities
– two ships, locked side by side, their
crews crossing swords, their captains dueling
to the death.
Maybe you even imagine the ungroomed pirate
who’s been marooned on an island, biding
his time before he unleashes a bold escape
plan.
How long before you think of Blackbeard?
Of Captain Kidd?
Black Bart Roberts?
Johnny Depp?
Those men were fearsome, exceptional pirates,
who used overlooked intelligence and feral
charm to rob the Caribbean blind during the
height of all piracy.
History has made them exemplars of the Golden
Age of Piracy.
Beyond the top-rate pirates, somewhere on
down the line… that’s where you’ll find
the English man born under the name John Rackham,
immortalized by his Pirate moniker, Calico
Jack.
The Pirate Republic
The Golden Age of Piracy was well underway
when our protagonist Mr. Rackham first appeared
in another man’s spyglass.
This was the “Classical” age of Pirates,
where Scallywags sailed the seven seas and
robbed the rich coffers of Spanish, French,
and English ships and colonies.
It lasted around 80 years, from roughly 1650
to 1730.
Every great epoch needs a cultural center,
and for the Pirates, that was Nassau.
Decades before loyalist settlers escaped the
American Revolution by fleeing to the Bahamas,
Nassau became an overnight pirate haven, with
rogues of all kind fleeing unfriendly ports
to congregate on one massive, pirate-friendly
island.
Even though it only became a pirate port around
1715 – just a few short years before the
end of the Age – Nassau would represent
the Pirate way of life better than any other
ship, cove, or port.
Pirates were a curious lot.
They spent their days relieving hard-working
merchants of their wares, and they wasted
their nights trying to drink all the rum in
the western hemisphere.
You’d be forgiven for thinking that these
brigands and rogues were just Caribbean Vikings
with bigger ships and curvy swords, but in
between all the violence and swashbuckling,
pirates could be surprisingly progressive.
Many of the pirates that set anchor off Nassau
were once soldiers or merchants for one Crown
or another, and the system chewed them up
and spit them out.
They were decommissioned, unprotected, or
otherwise abandoned by their government, so
they turned to a way of life that promised
independence and self-sufficiency, if nothing
else.
Nassau and the crews that operated there became
something of a strange democracy, where men
who were committed to the pirate’s anti-establishment
code always had a place to stay and a voice
to share.
In the early 18th century, the voices that
carried loudest often came from men whose
names survived the ensuing centuries: Charles
Vane.
Samuel Bellamy.
Benjamin Hornigold.
Edward England.
John Rachham [comedic pause] was not one of
these men.
He was a B-list pirate at best, working as
the quartermaster for Charles Vane’s crew.
Rackham talked a big game, as many pirates
may have at the time, but the reality is that
he begins our story as only a lieutenant on
a far more prominent pirate’s ship.
Despite his lowly status, relative to the
other infamous pirates of his time, Rackham
and his peers were enjoying the absolute heights
of the Golden Age of Piracy.
Nassau was pure paradise – a centrally located
hideout that made it easy for Vane’s accomplished
crew to escape out to sea, rob a few ships,
then high-tail it back to their Bohemian base.
The island itself was heavily fortified, thanks
to both natural features and manmade defenses,
making it nearly impossible for individual
pirate hunters or navy ships to chase down
pirates that went to ground there.
Once on the island, a thriving pirate community
offered all the food, rum, and women a pirate
could ever ask for.
It was a never-ending party, thrown by pirates
and enjoyed by pirates.
There were no laws, no rules, and opportunities
for plunder all around.
What could possibly go wrong?
Between a Rack and a Hard Place
For the first 15 years of the 18th century,
nearly all of Europe was enraptured in the
War of the Spanish Succession.
Most of the great powers of Western and Central
Europe had some sort of claim to the Spanish
throne after the death of Charles II in 1700,
and the continent spent a decade and a half
sorting out the ensuing conflicts.
By the time it was over, pirates had complete
command of the Caribbean, and were engaging
in all sorts of shameless piratey behavior
with impunity.
When King George the First realized something
had to be done to end the piracy, he issued
the Proclamation for Suppressing of Pirates
on September 5, 1717.
All pirates had one year to turn themselves
in to a colonial governor and receive complete
clemency for all past actions.
No tricks.
No traps.
Pirates could end their pirating and take
up a normal life with a normal trade.
For an age often marked by near-absolute monarchical
power and, it was a pretty sweet deal for
a bunch of dirty commoners.
It may have even been a tacit admission from
the King that the government could have acted
better, or provided better, for those who
felt a pirate’s life was their only real
hope as a healthy life.
The “King’s Pardon,” as it would come
to be known in Nassau, deeply divided the
Pirate Republic.
Some felt that the English Crown prioritizing
the end of Piracy surely meant that the party
was over.
A few may have even wanted to take those democratic
pirate principles and try to build a real
country.
But the most vocal group were the “pure”
pirates, who declared they’d never bow to
the crown.
Rackham and the rest of Vane’s crew were
squarely in the latter camp.
So when George sent former privateer Woodes
Rogers to clean up Nassau and end the party
once and for all, Vane and Rackham felt obliged
to welcome the would-be governor with a pirate’s
greeting.
In July of 1718, Vane arranged for a small
group of ships to set anchor off the island
and fire at Rogers’ incoming frigate; he
also set a ship on fire and sailed it directly
at Rogers in the hope of destroying his retinue
in a slightly more theatrical way.
Rogers ultimately survived the attack, while
Rackham and his crew escaped out to sea amid
the chaos.
Vane and Rackham spent the next four months
terrorizing Nassau, Jamaica, and other nearby
islands.
While Rogers slowly convinced pirates to accept
the King’s Pardon, Quartermaster John Rackham
was coordinating more attacks than ever.
And so it was that protagonist Jack came to
his first real spot of trouble.
In November of 1718 – four months after
Vane tried to blow up Rogers’s ship, and
two months after the deadline for the King’s
Pardon – John Rackham and his warmongering
friends set their sights on a magnificent
new prize.
This was a French warship, almost certainly
filled to the brim with rum, raw materials,
sugar, tobacco, and who knows what else.
Rackham and his friends badly wanted to take
it for themselves.
Captain Vane gave the order to engage, but
he quickly realized the pirates were outgunned,
and their ship’s superior speed would not
be enough to best the warship.
Vane wanted to retreat and live to fight another
day – an idea that his bloodthirsty crew
was appalled by.
It was a no-win situation for the veteran
captain: he could face immediate death by
fighting a hopeless battle against a massive
warship, or face a potential mutiny by upsetting
his increasingly violent crew.
Vane was in command, at least for the moment,
so he ordered an unpopular retreat.
But after the pirates had safely escaped the
French ship, the crew of 70 were predictably
mad at the lack of a score.
Ever the democracy, Vane’s pirates took
a vote, and the vast majority of them were
ready for a change in leadership.
Charles Vane and his band of supporters were
given a small schooner they had captured days
before, and they weresent away.
In his place, the crew had elected a new man,
one who appeared more capable of delivering
the mayhem and bloody piracy the crew was
searching for: Calico Jack Rackham.
A Memorable Wardrobe; A Forgettable Pirate
Many
a pirate that
sailed through the Caribbean developed some
sort of nickname, and newly minted pirate
captain John Rackham was no exception.
Rackham had a habit of wearing eye-catching
clothing made from colorful Indian Calico
cloth; thus, Calico Jack was born on the high
seas.
Unfortunately, it didn’t take long for Rackham
to realize he made a much better quartermaster
than he did a captain.
It was easy to advocate for bold plans and
violent delights as a crew member, but Calico
Jack soon found that designing and executing
glorious pirate plans was a lot harder than
it looked.
Like a modern-day politician who regrets the
promises he made on the way to his election,
Calico Jack suddenly had to provide all the
plundering that his peers had demanded from
Vane.
What’s more, he had to do it while Governor
Woodes Rogers had begun executing pirates
and cleaning up the region.
Rackham started small, targeting low-rent
merchants or undefended coastline.
He found modest success, and even executed
a crafty plan that made it into the pages
of Captain Charles Johnson’s A General History
of Pyrates.
According to Johnson, Calico Jack and crew
had parked their sloop off the coast of Cuba,
and a few men had gone ashore to resupply
the ship with fresh food, rum, and ammunition.
At low tide, as the sun was setting, a Spanish
gunship responsible for patrolling the Cuban
coastline had sailed into view and spotted
the pirates.
This was a powerful ship, that already had
a captured English sloop in tow.
The Spanish couldn’t mount a proper attack
at low tide, so they decided to wait until
morning, then attack the pirates at first
light.
Calico Jack and his Crew spotted the Spanish
warship and devised a plan.
Rather than try to escape from the port at
low tide, Rackham ordered the ship abandoned,
as everyone fled to shore.
As the Spanish ship fired on the pirate sloop
at daybreak, the pirates snuck aboard the
captured English sloop, incapacitated the
guards, and sailed away before the frigate
could realize what had happened.
It was a nifty move, and one that likely marked
the high point of Rackham’s tenure as a
pirate captain.
But Captain Jack had just as many setbacks
as he did successes.
In December of 1718, for example, he targeted
a large merchant ship called the Kingston
for, ahem, repossession, but drew up a lousy
plan that almost got he and his crew killed.
Rackham liked the Kingston because it was
carrying a hugely valuable cargo, but didn’t
wait to seize the ship at a tactically isolated
area; instead, the crew jumped aboard within
sight of Jamaica’s Port Royal, where the
pirates could easily be identified and tracked
by the ship’s merchants.
They hired bounty hunters, who caught up with
the ship several weeks later, at Isla de los
Pinos, off the western end of Cuba.
Historians are unsure what happened next – some
report that Calico Jack and his crew had all
gone to land and passed out drunk, leaving
their conquest undefended with the loot still
aboard.
Other versions suggest that Jack was a coward,
opting to hide in the woods rather than fight
the hunters.
Either way, Rackham was in no position to
do anything about it, and he quickly lost
his best capture before he had the chance
to make any money off the score.
Calico Jack wasn’t disciplined enough to
consistently pull off successful pirate heists,
and he wasn’t foolhardy enough to launch
blind attacks and let the doubloons fall where
they may.
So a few months after overthrowing his captain
and living large at sea, Rackham and his crew
decided to give up, return to Nassau, and
try to convince Governor Rogers to extend
them a pardon, months after the King’s deadline.
Upon landing at Nassau, Rackham and his crew
were bound and taken before Rogers, where
Calico Jack informed him that deposed captain
Charles Vane was the real enemy here.
You see, none of them actually wanted to be
pirates!
But Vane had pressed them into service, forcing
them to do rob, rape, and ransack every village
in the West Indies.
Once wholesome John Rackham had let a successful
mutiny against Vane, those good-hearted pirates
sailed straight back to Nassau, hoping to
return to normal, productive lives under the
English Crown.
It was, quite accidentally, a completely brilliant
plan.
Governor Rogers had never forgiven Vane for
the fireship stunt upon his arrival and had
continued to hold a grudge against him.
So in 1719, Rogers officially pardoned Calico
Jack and his crew, and they all settled down
to live a clean, decent life, free of piracy.
Annie, Get Your Flintlock Pistol
For all we know, John Rackham genuinely did
mean to give up his life on the lam when he
returned to Nassau and accepted Woodes Roger’s
pardon.
However, Rackham hadn’t accounted for the
one variable that can make a man do just about
anything.
It wasn’t long back on land before our former
pirate captain ran into a ravishing, red-haired
woman in a Bohemian pub.
Anne Bonny was an Irish lass that immediately
captured Rackham’s attention.
The two had instant chemistry and were immediately
smitten with each other.
As Rackham settled back into civilian life,
he wanted to take Anne as his wife, to have
and to hold, as they lived out their days
in the sun and the sand.
There was just one problem.
Anne was already married.
Anne must have had a type, because her husband
was also a former pirate named John.
John Bonny had happily taken the pardon and
accepted a new job, working directly for Governor
Rogers as an informant on pirate activity.
In short, he was a snitch, helping Rogers
bring the remaining Pirates of the Caribbean
to justice.
Rackham and Anne Bonny tried everything they
could think of in order to start a new life
together.
They pleaded directly to John Bonny, with
Anne declaring her love for another man.
When he said no, they took their case to Rogers,
asking that he consider annulling the marriage
as provincial governor and John Bonny’s
boss.
In a proposal that’s both sweet and sexist,
Rackham even suggested “Divorce Via Purchase”
as an option, offering to buy Anne from John
Bonny.
Nothing worked.
With no other options available to them, Calico
Jack and his lover Anne Bonny decided a Pirate’s
Life was their last recourse.
So in August of 1720, Jack, Anne, and a few
other friendly ex-pirates stole a ship from
Nassau Harbor and returned to the sea.
Anne Bonny may very well be the reason we
remember Calico Jack at all.
Many sailors at the time believed that having
a woman aboard a ship was bad luck – even
well-respected pirates like Blackbeard wouldn’t
allow them on his ship, let alone take up
arms alongside one.
Successful female pirates were awfully rare,
even during the Golden Age of Piracy, which
explains why some sources report that Anne
may have hidden her gender from everyone but
her lover and co-captain.
During Calico Jack’s second tour of pirate
duty, some records seem to indicate that it
was Anne who was both the brains and the brawn
of the operation.
Years of living through a bad marriage had
given her an edge, which she unleashed by
seizing dozens of ships and killing any captives
who might threaten to undermine the operation
or rat them out to provincial governor.
There’s plenty of legends that have raised
up around Anne Bonny, the Pirate Lass, including
the time she tricked a French crew into surrendering
by standing over a bloodied mannequin with
a raised axe.
Rackham, by contrast, was mostly enjoying
the sex and partying that a piracy lifestyle
afforded him.
He enjoyed his new life with Anne, unencumbered
by the burdens of proper civilization, and
would often invite sailors from captured ships
to drink with him.
Some even stayed on as new crew members.
One such sailor who joined Calico Jack’s
entourage was yet another woman in disguise:
Mary Read.
Anne and Mary became fast friends, with each
seeing through the other’s disguise.
Both were elated to find some female companionship
on the open ocean and began confiding in each
other.
In a bit that might as well be pulled straight
from 12th Night, Calico Jack began to grow
jealous of the gabby lad who Anne was suddenly
spending so much time with.
Eventually, Anne had to cue her man in on
Mary’s secret!
And for the rest of their days on the sea,
the fearsome threesome carried out raids and
thefts, with no one else realizing that two
of the Caribbean’s fiercest remaining pirates
were hiding breasts under their coats.
Rackham’s Cay
Unfortunately for Anne, Mary, and Calico Jack,
their adventure at sea wouldn’t last more
than a few months.
Leaving a relatively calm life to become a
pirate would be dangerous for anyone; leaving
your pirate-snitch husband, absconding with
a former pirate, and aggressively robbing
every merchant ship from Mexico to the Florida
Keys – well, that’s practically suicide.
It took all of one month for Governor Woodes
Rogers to announce a bounty for Calico Jack,
Anne Bonny and their crew, and another month
after that before bounty hunters were hot
on their trail.
The walls were closing around John Rackham,
and there would be no clever lie to save him
this time around.
It was only a matter of time before the pirate
hunters caught up to them, which is precisely
what happened in the final weeks of 1720.
Hunters led by Captain Jonathan Barnet boarded
the ship, meaning to bring everyone aboard
back to Jamaica to be tried for piracy.
Mary and Anne mounted a hellish, boisterous
defense of the pirates, but eventually, they
were outnumbered.
Once again, accounts differ here – some
say Calico Jack was too drunk below deck to
offer a proper defense, while other reports
say he simply recognized he was beaten and
quietly laid down his arms.
Whatever the truth, while the women of the
ship were prepared to fight until their last
breath, John Rackham offered no resistance.
He let himself be captured and imprisoned
without much resistance, as his remaining
crew watched in horror and disgust.
Justice came swiftly for Calico Jack and his
crew.
Anne Bonny and Mary Read were spared from
the gallows, as both were pregnant when captured.
But the remaining crew – including Rackham
– were sentenced to hang, less than a month
later, in Port Royal, Jamaica.
Before he died, Anne allegedly visited her
lover Rackham in prison.
He was overjoyed to see her one last time;
she merely scoffed, telling him that “if
you had fought like a man, you need not have
hanged like a dog.”
He was hanged just a few days later, on November
18, 1720, at age 37.
As was the case with many pirates of their
day, Rackham’s corpse was gibbeted, or hung
on display as a warning to other pirates.
The Jamaicans chose to hang Calico Jack’s
body on a small islet outside of Port Royal
– a tiny piece of land known now as Rackham’s
Cay.
It’s probably fitting that John Rackham’s
most lasting impact on the world around him
was a monument to his own failure.
Calico Jack was not the brightest pirate to
ever steer a schooner, nor was he the boldest.
In truth, he was an imperfect pirate who accomplished
very little and earned his fame primarily
by the company he kept.
He was outlived by Charles Vane, his former
mentor, who eventually found himself marooned
on an island in the aftermath of a hurricane.
He was also outlived by his partner, Anne
Bonny, who likely escaped from her Jamaican
prison and lived a full life.
The prison has no record of Bonny’s execution
or release; as a result, most histories take
that to mean she slinked away and lived a
full life.
Her recorded death date is decades later,
in the 1780s.
So Rackham didn’t manage to outlive most
of his peers, in the latter portion of the
Golden Age of Piracy.
He was never as well-respected, either; men
like Blackbeard and Hornigold are nearly always
referenced as quintessential late-era figures,
with Rackham sinking into the background.
Even as a pirate, he fell short – his best
prize, the Kingston, was stolen back from
him after mere weeks.
Perhaps worst of all, his reputation as a
pirate was blackened by too many surrenders
and too few fights.
He went to his death disrespected by his former
crew and confidants.
Captain Jack was indeed one of the worst pirates
you’ve ever heard of.
But if he was here to defend himself today,
he might just point out that you have, in
fact, heard of him.